[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
MICHAEL SIPSER: So,
welcome, everybody,
to the Fall 2020 online
Introduction to the Theory
of Computing 18.404/6.840.
My name is Mike Sipser.
I'm going to be your instructor
for the semester in this class.
So let me just tell you
what the course is about.
Basically, it's going
to be in two halves.
We're going to be talking
about what are the capabilities
and limitations of computers--
of computer algorithms,
really, computation.
And the two parts of the
course are more or less divided
in half.
The first half of
the course is going
to talk about a subject called
computability theory, which
it really asks what
you can compute
with an algorithm in principle.
That's-- was an active area of
research in the earlier part
of the 20th century.
It's pretty much closed
off as a research subject
these days, mainly
because they answered
all of their big questions.
And so a mathematical
field really only
stays vital when it
has problems to solve,
and they really solved all of
their interesting problems--
for the most part, not 100%.
But for the most part, it sort
of finished off in the 1950s--
just to say a little bit
more about what we're
going to talk about there.
When you're interested to
know what kinds of problems
you can solve with
an algorithm--
there are problems
that you might
want to solve that
you just can't solve.
For example, given a
specification for a computer
problem you want
to solve, whatever
that specification might be--
say your algorithm
actually is a sorting
algorithm, for example--
and you want to write
down that specification
and have an automatic
verifier that's
going to check whether a
program meets the specification.
Well, that's just in
principle impossible.
You cannot make a verifier
which is going to answer,
in all cases, whether or not
a program meets a certain
specification.
So with things like that,
we will prove this semester.
Questions about
mathematical truth--
if you're given a mathematical
statement, is it true
or is it false?
It'd be great if you can
write a computer program that
would answer that problem.
Well, it would not be great
if you were a mathematician,
because that would put
us all out of business.
But you can imagine that
might be a nice thing to have,
but you can't.
I mean, there is no algorithm
which can answer that question.
Well, along the way, we're
going to introduce models
of computation, like finite
automata, which we'll
see today, Turing machines,
and some other models
that we'll see along the way.
The second half of
the course, which
is going to be
after the midterm,
we're going to
shift gears and talk
about complexity theory, which
is instead of looking at what's
computable in
principle, you're going
to look at what's computable
in practice, so things
that you can solve in a
reasonable amount of time.
And, for example,
I'm sure many of you
are aware of the factoring
problem, which has connections
to the RSA cryptosystem,
cryptography, and asks
whether you can factor
big numbers quickly.
That's a problem we
don't know the answer to.
We just don't know how to
factor big numbers quickly.
But it's possible that there
are algorithms out there
that we haven't discovered
yet that can do so.
It's connected with
this very famous problem
in the intersection
of computer science
and mathematics called the
P versus NP problem, which
many of you may have heard of.
We'll talk about that.
We'll spend a lot of
time on that this term.
And along the way, we'll
talk about different measures
of complexity, of
computation, time and space,
time and memory, theoretical
memory, electrical space.
That's going to be a big part
of the course in the complexity
theory part--
introduce other
models of computation,
such as probabilistic and
interactive computation.
Talk about the
expectations of the course.
First of all, prerequisites.
There are a bunch of
prerequisites listed, 6.042,
18.062 , or maybe some
other subject as well.
The real thing is that
this is a math class.
This is a class where--
and it's not a
beginning math class,
this is a moderate-to-advanced
math class.
And I'm expecting
people to have had
some prior experience,
of a substantial nature,
with mathematical
theorems and proofs.
We'll start off slow, but we're
going to ramp up pretty fast.
So if you haven't
really got the idea
or gotten comfortable with
doing proofs, coming up
with proofs to
mathematical statements,
that's going to be a concern.
I would just be
monitoring yourself
and seeing how you're doing.
Because the homeworks
and the exams
are going to count on
your being able to produce
proofs, and so you're
going to be struggling
if that's going to be a real--
something that you haven't
had experience with.
And let me talk a little
bit about the role
of theory in computer science.
This is a theory
class, as you know.
So before we jump
into the material,
I just thought it would
be worth it for you
to give you at
least my perspective
on the role of theoretical
computer science
within the field.
So I've been in computer
science for a long time.
I go back-- I'm sure I'm
getting to be a dinosaur here--
but I go back to the days
when you had punch cards.
That's what we did when
I was an undergraduate.
And, obviously, things
are very different now.
And you can argue
that computer science
as a discipline has matured,
and sort of the basic stuff
has all been solved.
Well, I would say there's
a certain truth to that,
but there's a
certain way in which
I would say that's not true.
I think we're still
at the very beginning,
at least in certain
respects, of computer science
as a discipline.
For one thing, there
are a lot of things
that we do, a lot of things
relating to computation,
that we just don't know
the answer to-- very
fundamental things.
Let's take as an example,
how does the brain work?
Obviously, the brain computes
in a certain fashion.
And we've made good
progress, you can argue,
with machine learning and all
of those things that have very--
very powerful and
doing very cool things.
But I would also say that at
some deeper level, the methods
that we have so far don't allow
us to understand creativity.
We're not close to being able to
create a computer program that
can do mathematics
or that can do
many of the creative
kinds of things
that human beings can do.
I think machine learning,
powerful as it is,
is really successful only for
a very narrow set of tasks.
And so I think there's probably
something deeper and more
fundamental going on
that we're missing.
That would be my hunch.
Now, whether something like
theoretical computer science is
going to give you an answer
there-- or this kind of theory,
or some kind of theory--
I think some kind of theory
has at least a decent shot
at playing a role in helping
us to understand computation
in a deeper way.
And the fact that we can't
understand something as basic
as, can you factor a big
number quickly or not?
You can't really say you
understand computation
until you can answer
questions like that.
So I would argue that
we have a really very
primitive understanding of
computation at this stage
and that there is a lot that
has yet to be discovered,
not just on the
technological side,
but just on the very fundamental
theoretical side that
has a real shot at playing
a role in affecting
the practice of how
we use computers.
And so I think for
that reason-- again,
I'm not sure what kind of theory
is going to be the most useful,
but the theory we're going
to cover in this course
is a particularly
elegant theory,
and it has already paid
off in many applications
and in terms of our
understanding of computation.
And I think, at least
as a starting point,
it's a good subject to learn.
Certainly, I enjoy it, and
I've spent a good chunk
of my career doing that.
So let's move on then and begin
with the subject material.
So we're going to talk
about models of computation,
as I mentioned.
We want to try to
understand computers,
and we want to understand
what computers can do.
But computers in the real world
are pretty complicated objects,
and they're really not nice
to talk about mathematically.
So we're going to talk about
abstract models of computers
that are much simpler
but really capture--
just like models in general--
capture the important
aspects of the thing
we're trying to understand.
And so we're going to look
at several different kinds
of models that vary in their
capabilities and the way
they approximate
the real computers
that we deal with every day.
And for starters, we're going
to look at a very simple model
called the finite automaton.
And that's going to represent--
you can think of it as
representing a computer that
has a very small
amount of memory
and a very limited and
small amount of memory.
And we're going to look
at the capabilities
of those kinds of machines.
And what's nice about them is
that you can understand them
very well.
And so more powerful models that
we're going to look at later
are going to be harder to
understand in as deep a way.
But for these, we can develop
a very comprehensive theory.
And so that's what we're going
to do for the next lecture
and a half.
So I'm starting off
with an example.
I'm presenting a finite
automaton as a diagram--
we call it a state diagram.
It has these circles and
lines and labels on the lines
and also on these circles.
So what's going on here?
So this is a finite automaton.
I'm giving it the name M1.
And it has-- these
circles are called states.
So in this case, there were
three states, q1, q2, and q3.
Those are the labels there.
There are arrows connecting
states with each other.
So these we'll call transitions.
And they're going
to tell you how
to compute with this device.
And there's going to be a
specially-designated starting
state, which has an arrow
coming in from nowhere.
And there are other
specially-designated states
called accepting
states, and that's
going to have to do with
how the machine computes.
But those are the ones that
have these double circles.
And so talking about
the way it computes,
the idea is pretty simple.
The input is going to
be some finite string
of 0's and 1's, in this case.
We might have other types
of symbols that are allowed
for other automata, but the
example that I have here,
it's going to be 0's and 1's.
And the way you
compute with the thing
is you first put your finger--
which I can't do on Zoom,
so I'll use the pointer--
you put your pointer
on the starting state,
the one that has the arrow
coming in from nowhere.
First, you put
your pointer there.
And then are you
start reading symbols
from the input,
one after the next.
So let's take an
example here, 01101.
So you start reading
those symbols,
and you follow
those transitions.
So you go 0--
and you go back
to the same state.
Then you go-- the
next symbol is a 1,
so you go over to this
state, from q1 to q2.
Now you have another
one that comes in.
So now you're starting at
q2, you have another one,
so you follow its
associated transition.
So if you notice,
every state has
an outgoing transition for 1
and another outgoing transition
for 0.
So there's always somewhere to
go every time you read symbols
from the input.
So now you're at q2.
You read that next, that
third symbol, which is a 1.
That's going to
take you over to q3.
And now you have a
0, which loops you
back to where you were, and
another 1, which loops you
back to where you were.
And because you ended
up at an accept,
you say we accept that string.
So that's going to be the
output of this finite automaton.
For each string,
it's either going
to accept it or reject it.
So it's just a binary decision
that is going to be made.
It's sort of like
a 1 or a 0 output,
but we're calling
it accept or reject.
So this one here,
because it ended up
at the accepting
state, is accepted.
But if you look at the
second example, 00101,
so you're going to
have 0, 0, 1, 0, 1.
Now we ended up at q2.
That's not an accepting state.
So therefore, we say
we reject this input.
OK?
Very simple.
And now, for example,
one of the questions
you might want to ask,
given one of these things,
is, well, which are
exactly those strings
that the machine accepts?
And a little bit of
thought will help
you understand that
the only strings which
are going to take you over
to q3 are those strings that
have a 11 appearing
somewhere along the way, two
consecutive 1's, and you will
end up at the accepting state.
I encourage you to think
about that for a minute
if not immediately obvious.
But those are the
strings that are going
to be accepted by this machine.
And we call that
collection of strings
the language of the machine.
So that set A of
those strings that
have a 11, for this particular
machine, is the language of M1.
We also say that M1 recognizes
that language, recognizes A.
And in terms of notation,
we write that A is L of M1.
A is the language of M1.
So the language of a machine
is exactly the set of strings
that machine accepts.
OK?
So one of the first things we're
going to want to be able to do
is take a machine
and understand what
its language is, what's
the set of strings
that that machine accepts.
Another thing we might want
to do is, given a language,
build a machine which
recognizes that language.
And then understanding, what
are the class of languages?
Can you get any language
from some machine,
or are there going to be some
languages that you can do
and other languages
that you cannot do?
So those are the
kinds of questions
we're going to be asking
about these finite automata.
What kinds of things
can those machines do,
and what can they not do?
OK.
Here's our next check-in.
So wake up, everybody
who's not paying attention.
A check-in is coming.
So we have more
questions, though I
can't keep-- are these
three statements equivalent?
What three statements?
AUDIENCE: At the
bottom of the slide.
MICHAEL SIPSER: Oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, yes.
Those three are equivalent.
A is the language-- yeah,
those mean the same thing.
Not only are they equivalent,
but they're just different ways
of saying the same thing.
That M1 recognizes
the language is
the same as saying that's
the language of the machine
and that A equals
that L of M. That's
all the same way of saying they
all-- six of one, half a dozen
of the other.
It's two ways of
saying the same thing.
OK, so let's pop up our
poll and get that started.
Whoops.
Still showing the old
one-- oh, here we go.
Move it to the next question.
OK.
OK, so you understand
the question here?
Where do we end up
after we read 101?
What state are we in?
Do we end up in
state q1, q2, or q3?
OK?
Go fast.
This is a--
OK, so I think we got
pretty much converged here.
I think almost
everybody got it right.
The answer is indeed that
you ended up in state q2.
Because you go 1,
0, 1, and that's
where you ended up, in state q2.
So is this string accepted?
No, because you didn't
end up at an accept state.
So this machine rejects 101.
OK, let's keep going.
So now-- yeah.
OK, so now we gave
it this informal idea
of a finite automaton.
We're going to have to try to
get a formal definition now,
which is going to be a more
mathematical way of saying
the same thing that I just said.
And the reason for having
a formal definition
is, for one thing, it allows
us to be very precise.
Then we'll know exactly what
we mean by a finite automaton,
and it should answer any
questions about what counts
and what doesn't count.
It also is a way of
providing notation.
So it'll help us
describe finite automata.
And sometimes there might be an
automaton where the picture is
just too big, so you might
want to be able to describe it
in some mathematical
terminology rather
than by giving a picture.
Or maybe you're
going to be asked
to give a family
of automata, where
there is going to be a
parameter, N, associated
with the class of
languages you're trying
to describe with the automaton.
And then it'll be more
helpful to describe it
in this formal notation rather
than as a kind of a picture,
because it might be
infinitely many pictures that
are being needed.
So maybe examples of
that will come up now.
So a finite automaton,
we call it a 5-tuple.
Don't be put off by that.
A 5-tuple is just a
list of five things.
So a finite automaton,
in our definition,
is going to have
five components.
It's going to have
Q, which is going
to be a finite set
of states, so it's
going to be a finite set,
which we'll designate
as the states of the automaton.
Sigma is the alphabet
symbols of the automaton,
another finite set.
Delta is the
transition function.
That tells us how the automaton
moves from state to state.
Those describes how
those transition arrows--
those arrows which connected
the states with each other--
it describes them in
a mathematical way
instead in terms of a picture.
And the way I'm doing
that is with a function.
So delta is a function
which takes two things.
So I'm hoping you've seen
this notation before.
I'll help you through
it once, but this
is the kind of
thing I would expect
you to have seen already.
So we have Q cross sigma.
So I'm going to give delta a
state and an alphabet symbol.
So Q is states, sigma
is alphabet symbols.
So you're going to get a
state and an alphabet symbol,
and it's going to
give you back a state.
So describing it kind of
a little bit more detail,
delta, if you give it state
q and symbol a equals r,
that means q, when you
read an a, you go to r.
So that's the way this
picture gets translated
into a mathematical
function, which
describes those transitions.
And then now q0 is going
to be the starting state.
That's the one with the
arrow coming in from nowhere.
And F is the set of
accepting states.
So there's only going to
be one starting state,
but there might be
several different--
or possibly even 0--
accepting states.
That's all legal when we
have a finite automaton.
And so in terms of
using the notation--
going back to the machine that
we just had from the previous
slide, which I've
given you here again--
let me show you how
I would describe
this using this notation that
comes out of the definition.
So here is M1 again.
It's this 5-tuple where Q
now is the set-- q1, q2, q3--
that's the set of states.
The input alphabet is 0, 1.
It might vary in other automata.
And f is the set q3,
which has only the element
q3, because this has just
one accept state, q3.
So I hope that's helpful.
Oh, of course, I forgot the
transition function, which
here I'm describing as a table.
So the transition
function says if you
have a state and
an input alphabet,
you can look up in
the table where you're
supposed to go under
the transition function
according to the state
and the alphabet symbol
that you're given.
So, for example, if we were
in state q2 here getting a 0,
then q2 goes back to q1
so that q2 on 0 is q1.
But q2 on 1 here is q3.
OK?
So that's how that table
captures this picture.
OK?
And it's just a function.
It's a way of representing a
function, a finite function,
in terms of this table here.
So I realize, for some
of you, this may be slow.
We will ramp up
in speed, but I'm
trying to get us all
together in terms
of the language of the
course here at the beginning.
OK, so now let's
talk about some more
the computation, so
strings and languages.
A string is just
a finite sequence
of symbols from the alphabet.
This class is not going to
talk about infinite strings.
All of our strings are
going to be finite.
There's other mathematical
theories of automata
and so on that talk
about infinite inputs
and infinite strings.
We're not going to
talk about that.
Maybe rarely, we'll
make it very clear,
we'll talk about
an infinite string,
but that's going
to be an exception.
And a language is
a set of strings.
That's the traditional way
that people in this subject
refer to a set of strings.
They call it a language--
really because the subject
had its roots in
linguistics, actually.
And they were talking
about-- they're
trying to understand
languages, human languages.
So this is just a
historical fact,
and that's the
terminology that's stuck.
OK, so two special string--
a special string and
a special language.
The empty string is
the string of length 0.
This is a totally
legitimate string
that you are going to
run into now and then.
And there's the
empty language, which
is the set with no strings.
These are not the same.
They're not even of the
same type of object.
So don't confuse them
with one another.
I mean, you can have
a set, a language,
which has just one element,
which is the empty string.
That is not the empty set.
That is a set-- that is
not the empty language.
That is a language that
has one element in it,
namely, the empty string.
So those are separate things.
OK, so here's a little bit of
a mouthful here on the slide,
defining what it means for an
automaton to accept its input--
accepts its input string w.
And we can define that formally.
And it's a little
technical looking,
it's really not that bad.
So if you have your
input string w,
which you can write as
a sequence of symbols
in the alphabet-- w1, w2, dot
dot dot, wn, so like 01001.
I'm just writing it out
symbol by symbol here.
So what does it mean for the
machine to accept that input?
So that means that there's
a sequence of states
in the machine, sequence of
states of members of Q. So
a sequence from Q,
these are the states
of the machine that satisfy
these three properties down
here.
First of all-- and I'm
thinking about the sequence
that the machine goes through
as it's processing the input w.
So when does it accept w?
If that sequence has the feature
that it starts at the start
state, each state legally
follows the previous state
according to the
transition function.
So that says the i-th
member of the sequence
is obtained by looking
at the previous one--
the i minus first member of
that sequence, the i minus
first state in that
sequence-- and then
looking at what happens when
you take the i-th input symbol.
So as you look at the previous
state and the next input
symbol, you should
get the next state.
That's all that this is saying.
And this should happen for
each one of these guys.
And lastly, for
this to be accepted,
the very last member
here, where we ended up
at the end of the input--
so you only care about this
you have to be in
an accepting state.
So you can mathematically
capture this notion
of going along this path.
And that's what--
I'm just trying to illustrate
that we could describe
all this very formally--
I'm not saying that's the
best way to think about it all
the time--
but that it can be done.
And I think that's something
worth appreciating.
OK.
So now in terms of, again,
getting back-- we've
said this once
already, but in terms
of the languages that
the machine recognizes,
it's the collection of strings
that the machine accepts.
Every machine accepts-- it
might accept many strings,
but it always recognizes
one particular language,
even if the machine
accepts no strings--
then it recognizes
the empty language.
So a machine always
recognizes one language,
but it may have many, many
strings that it's accepting.
And we call that language
the language of the machine.
And we say that M
recognizes that language.
These three things
mean the same thing.
OK?
And now important definition--
I try to reserve the
most important things
or the highlighted things to
be in this light blue color,
if you can see that.
We say a language is
a regular language
if there's some finite
automaton that recognizes it.
OK?
So there are going to be some
languages that have associated
to them finite automata that
actually solve those languages,
that recognize those languages.
But there might be
other languages--
and we'll see examples-- where
you just can't solve them.
You can't recognize them
with a finite automaton.
Those languages will not
be regular languages.
The regular ones are
the ones that you
can do with a finite automaton.
That's the traditional
terminology.
OK, so let's continue.
Let's go on from there.
So let's do a
couple of examples.
Here, again, is that same--
getting to be an old
friend, that automaton M1.
Remember, its language
here is the set
of strings that have
the substring 11.
That is that
language A. Now, what
do we know about A from
the previous slide?
Think with me.
Don't just listen.
A is a regular language
now, because it's
recognized by some automaton.
So whenever you
find an automaton
for a language, a finite
automaton for language,
we know that that language
is a regular language.
So let's look at a
couple of more examples.
So if you take the language--
let's call this one B, which
is the strings that have
an even number of 1's in them.
So like the string 1101,
would that be in B?
No, because it has
an odd number of 1's.
So the string 1111
has four 1's in it.
That's an even number, so
that string would be in B.
The 0's don't matter
for this language.
So strings that have
an even number of 1's,
that's a regular language.
And the way you would
know that is you
would have to make a
finite automaton that
recognizes that language.
And I would encourage you to
go and make that automaton.
You can do it with two states.
It's a very simple automaton.
But if you haven't had
practice with these,
I encourage you to do that.
And actually, there
are lots of examples
that I ask you to solve at the
end of chapter 1 in the book,
and you definitely should
spend some time playing with it
if you have not yet seen
finite automata before.
You need to get comfortable with
these and be able to make them.
So we're going to start
making some of them,
but we're going to
be talking about it
at a sort of a more
abstract level in a minute.
Basically, the reason why
you can solve this problem,
you can make a finite automaton
which recognizes the language
B, is because that
finite automaton
is going to keep track of the
parity of the number of 1's
it's seen before.
This has two states,
one of them remembering
that it's seen an odd
number of 1's so far,
the other one
remembering it's seen
an even number of 1's before.
And that's going to be
typical for these automata,
finite automata.
There's going to be several
different possibilities
that you may have to keep track
of as you're reading the input,
and there's going to
be a state associated
with each one of
those possibilities.
So if you're designing
an automaton,
you have to think about--
as you're processing the input--
what things you have
to keep track of.
And you're going to make
a state for each one
of those possibilities.
OK?
So you need to get
comfortable with that.
Let's look at another example,
the language C where the inputs
have an equal number
of 0's and 1's.
That turns out to be
not a regular language.
So, in other words,
what that means
is there's no way to
recognize that language
with a finite automaton.
You just can't do it.
That's beyond the capabilities
of finite automata.
And that's a statement
we will prove later.
OK.
And our goal over the
next lecture or so
is to understand the regular
languages, which you can
do in a very comprehensive way.
So we're going to
start to do that now.
So first, we're going to
introduce this concept
of regular expressions--
which, again, these
are things you
may have run into in one
way or another before.
So we're going to
introduce something
called the regular operations.
Now, I'm sure
you're familiar with
the arithmetical operations,
like plus and times.
Those apply to numbers.
The operations we're
going to talk about
are operations that
apply to languages.
So they're going to take,
let's say, two languages,
you apply an
operation, you're going
to get back another language.
Like the union
operation, for example,
that's one you probably
have seen before.
The union of two
languages here is
a collection of strings that
are in either one or the other.
But there are other
operations, which
you may not have seen before,
that we're going to look at--
the concatenation
operation, for example.
So that says you're
going to take
a string from the first
language and another string
from the second language
and stick them together.
And it's called
concatenating them.
And you do that in
all possible ways,
and you're going to get
the concatenation language
from these two languages
that you're starting with,
A and B. The symbol we
use for concatenation
is this little circle.
But often, we don't.
We just suppress that and
we write the two languages
next to one another with
the little circle implied.
So this also means concatenation
over here, just like this does.
And the last of the
regular operations
is the so-called star operation,
which is a unary operation.
It applies to just
a single language.
And so what you do is now
you're going to take--
to get a member of
the star language,
you're going to take
a bunch of strings
in the original language,
A, you stick them together.
Any number of members of
A, you stick them together,
and that becomes an element
of the star language.
And we'll do an example in a
second if you didn't get that.
But one important element is
that when you have the star
language, you can
also allow it to stick
zero elements together, and
then you get the empty string.
So that's always a
member of the star
language, the empty string.
OK, so let's look
at some examples.
Let's say A is the
language-- these are
two strings here-- good, bad.
And B is the language boy, girl.
Now, if we take the
union of those two,
we get good, bad, boy, girl.
That's kind of
what you'd expect.
And now let's take a look
at the concatenation.
Now, if you concatenate
the A and the B language,
you're going to get all
possible ways of having an A
string followed by all possible
ways of having a B string.
So you can get goodboy,
goodgirl, badboy, badgirl.
Now, looking at the
star, well, that
applies to just one language.
So let's say it's the
good, bad language from A.
And so the A star
that you get from that
is all possible ways of sticking
together the strings from A.
So using no strings, you
always get the empty string.
That's always guaranteed
to be a member of A.
And then just taking
one element of A,
you get good, or
another element, bad.
But now two elements of A,
you get goodgood or goodbad,
and so on.
Or three elements of A,
goodgoodgood, goodgoodbad.
And so, in fact, A star is
going to be an infinite language
if A itself contains
any non-empty member.
So if A is the empty
language or if A contains
just the language empty
string, then A star
will be not an
infinite language.
It'll just be the
language empty string.
But otherwise, it'll be
an infinite language.
I'm not even sure--
OK.
I'm not-- [LAUGHS]
I'm ignoring the chat here.
I'm hoping people
are getting-- are you
guys are getting your
questions answered by our TAs?
How are we doing, Thomas?
AUDIENCE: One question is, are
the slides going to be posted?
MICHAEL SIPSER: Are the
slides going to be posted?
Well, the whole lecture
is going to be recorded.
Is it helpful to have
the slides separately?
I can post the slides.
Sure.
Remind me if I don't,
but I'll try to do that.
Yes, it is helpful.
I will do that.
Yeah.
Yeah, I will post the slides.
Just, Thomas, it's
your job to remind me.
AUDIENCE: OK.
MICHAEL SIPSER: All right, good.
So we talked about the
regular operations.
Let's talk about the
regular expressions.
So regular
expressions are-- just
like you have the
arithmetical operations,
then you can get
arithmetical expressions,
like 1 plus 3 times 7.
So now we're going to
make expressions out
of these operations.
First of all, you have,
the more atomic things,
the building blocks of
the expressions, which
are going to be like elements of
sigma, elements of the alphabet
or the sigma itself
as an alphabet symbol,
or the empty language
or the empty string.
These are going to be
the building blocks
for the regular expressions.
We'll do an example in a second.
And then you combine
those basic elements
using the regular operations of
union, concatenation, and star.
So these are the
atomic expressions,
these are the
composite expressions.
So, for example, if you look at
the expression 0 union 1 star--
so we can also write
that as sigma star.
Because if sigma is 0
and 1, then sigma star
is the same thing as 0 union 1--
sigma is the same as 0 union 1.
And that just gives all
possible strings over sigma.
So this is something you're
going to see frequently.
Sigma star means
this is the language
of all strings over
the alphabet we're
working with at that moment.
Now, if you take
sigma star 1, you just
concatenate 1 onto all of
the elements of sigma star,
and that's going to give you
all strings that end with a 1.
Technically, you might
imagine writing this
with braces around the 1, but
generally, we don't do that.
We just-- single element
sets, single element strings,
we write without the
braces, because it's
clear enough without them,
and it gets messy with them.
So sigma star 1 is all
strings that end with 1.
Or, for example,
you take sigma star
11 sigma star, that is all
strings that contain 11.
And we already saw that
language once before.
That's the language
of that other machine
that we presented one
or two slides back.
OK?
Right.
Yeah, but in terms of
readings-- by the way,
sorry, I don't know
if it's helpful to you
for me to do these
interjections--
but the readings are listed
also on the homework.
So if you look at the
posted homework 1,
it tells you which chapters
you should be reading now.
And also, if you look at the
course schedule, which is also
on the home page, it has the
whole course plan and which
readings are for which dates.
So it's all there for you.
And so our goal here--
this is not an accident
that sigma star 11
sigma star happens
to be the same language
as we saw before
from the language of
that finite automaton M1.
In fact, that's a
general phenomenon.
Anything you can do with
a regular expression,
you can also do with a finite
automaton and vice versa.
They are equivalent
in power with respect
to the class of
languages they describe.
And we'll prove that.
OK?
So if you step back for
a second and just let
yourself appreciate this,
it's kind of an amazing thing.
Because finite automata, with
the states and transitions,
and the regular expressions,
with these operations of union,
concatenation, and star,
they look totally different
from one another.
They look like they have
nothing to do with one another.
But, in fact, they both describe
exactly the regular languages,
the same class of languages.
And so it's kind of a cool
fact that you can prove,
that these two very
different looking systems
actually are equivalent
to one another.
Can we get empty
string from empty set?
Yeah.
There are a bunch of
exotic cases, by the way.
So empty language star
is the language which
has just the empty string.
If you don't get that,
chew on that one.
But that is true.
OK, let's move on.
OK, let's talk about
closure properties now.
We're going to start doing
something that has a little bit
more meat to it,
in terms of we're
going to have our first theorem
of the course coming here.
And this is not a baby theorem.
This is actually-- there's
going to be some meat to this.
And you're going to
have to not totally--
this is not a toy.
We're proving something
that has real substance.
And the statement
of this theorem
says that the regular languages
are closed, that really,
the class of regular languages
are closed under union, closed
under the union operation.
So what do I mean by that?
So when you say a
collection of objects
is closed under
some operation, that
means applying that
operation to those objects
leaves you in the
same class of objects.
Like the positive integers,
the natural numbers,
that's closed under addition.
Because when you add
two positive integers,
you get back a positive integer.
But they're not closed
under subtraction.
Because 2 minus 4, you
get something which
is not a positive integer.
So closed means you leave
yourself in the collection.
And the fact is that if you look
at all the regular languages--
these are the languages that the
finite automata can recognize--
they are closed under
the union operation.
So if you start off with
two regular languages
and you apply the union, you get
back another regular language.
And that's what the
statement of this theorem is.
I hope that's clear enough
in the way I've written it.
If A1 and A2 are regular, then
A1 union A2 is also regular.
That's what the
statement of this is.
And it's just simply that--
that's proving that the
class of regular language
is closed under union.
So we're going to prove that.
So how do you
prove such a thing?
So the way we're going
to prove that is you
start off with what
we're assuming.
So our hypothesis is that we
have two regular languages.
And we have to prove
our conclusion,
that the union is also regular.
Now, the hypothesis
that they're regular,
you have to unpack that and
understand, what does that
get you?
And them being regular means
that there are finite automata
that recognize those languages.
So let's give those two
finite automata names.
So M1 and M2 are the
two final automata
that recognize those two
languages, A1 and A2.
That's what it means,
that they're regular,
that these automata exist.
So let's have those two
automata, M1 and M2,
using the components as we've
described, the respective state
sets, input alphabet,
transition functions, the two
starting states and the two
collections of accepting
states.
Here I'm assuming that they're
over the same alphabet.
You could have
automata which operate
over different alphabets.
It's not interesting to do that.
It doesn't add anything.
The proof would be
exactly the same.
So let's just not overcomplicate
our lives and focus
on the more interesting
case, so assuming
that the two input alphabets
are going to be the same.
And from these two
automata, we have
to show that this
language here, the union,
is also a regular language.
And we're going to do that
by constructing the automaton
which recognizes the union.
That's really the only
thing that we can do.
So we're going to build an
automaton out of M1 and M2
which recognizes the union
language A1 union A2.
And the task of M is that
it should accept its input
if either M1 or M2 accept.
And now what I'd
like you to think
about doing that,
how in the world
are we going to come up with
this finite automaton M?
And the way we do that is
to think about, how would
you do that union language?
If I ask you--
I give you two automata,
M1 and M2, and I say,
here's an input, w.
Is w in the union language?
That's the job that M
is supposed to solve.
And I suggest you
try to figure out
how you would solve it first.
I mean, this is a good
strategy for solving a lot
of the problems in this course.
Put yourself in the place of the
machine you're trying to build.
And so if you want to try to
figure out how to do that,
a natural thing is, well, you
take w, you feed it into M1,
and then you feed it into M2.
And if M1 accepts
it, great, then you
know it's in the union.
And if not, you try it out in
M2 and see if M2 accepts it.
Now, you have to be
a little careful,
because you want to have a
strategy that you can also
implement in a finite automaton.
And a finite automaton
only gets one shot
at looking at the input.
You can't sort of
rewind the input.
You feed it first into M1
and then you feed it into M2
and operate in a
sequential way like that.
That's not going to be allowed
in the way finite automata
work.
So you're going to have to
take it to the next level,
be a little bit more clever.
And instead of feeding
it first into M1
and then and then
into M2, you feed them
into both in parallel.
So you take M1 and
M2, and you run them
both in parallel on the input
w, keeping track of which state
each of those two
automata are in.
And then at the end, you see
if either one of those machines
is in an accepting state,
and then you accept.
So that's the
strategy we're going
to employ in building the finite
automaton M out of M1 and M2.
So in terms of a picture,
here's M1 and M2.
Here is the automaton
we're trying to build.
We don't know how it's
going to look like yet.
And yeah, so kind of getting
ahead of myself, but here
is a strategy, as I
just described, for M.
M is going to keep track of
which state that M1 is in
and which state M2 is
in at any given moment.
As we're reading
the symbols of w,
we're going to feed that
into M1 and also into M2.
And so the possibilities we
have to keep track of in M
are all the pairs of states
that are in M1 and M2,
because you're going
to really be tracking
M1 and M2 simultaneously.
So you have to remember
which state M1 is in and also
which state M2 is in.
And so that really corresponds
to what pair of states
to remember, one from M1
and one from M2, and that's
why I've indicated it like that.
So M1 is in state
q, M2 is in state r
at some given point in time.
And that's going to correspond
to M being in the pair q comma
r.
That's just the label of
this particular state of m
that we're going to apply here.
OK?
And then M is going
to accept if either M1
and M2 is an accepting state.
So it's going to be if either
q or r is an accepting state,
we're going to make this
into an accepting state too.
OK?
Whoops.
There we go.
So let's describe
this formally instead
of by a picture, because
we can do it both ways.
And sometimes it's better to
do it one way and sometimes
the other way.
So now if we take--
the components of M now are the
pairs of states from M1 and M2.
Again, I'm writing this out
literally, explicitly here,
but you should make sure
you're comfortable with
this cross product notation.
So this is the collection of
pairs of states, q1 and q2,
where q1 is in the state
of the first machine,
q2 is the state of
the second machine.
The start state is you
start at the two start
states of the two machines.
So this is q1, q2--
probably I should have
not reused the Q notation.
I should have called these r's--
now that I'm looking at that.
But, anyway, I hope you're
not confused by reusing this.
q1 and q2 here are the
specific start states
of the two machines.
These are just two other
states, representative states
of those machines.
Now, the transition
function for the new machine
is going to be built out
of the transition functions
from the previous machines.
So when I have a pair, q,
r, and I have the symbol a,
where do we go?
Which new pair do we get?
Well, we just update
the state from M1
and update the state
from M2 according
to their respective
transition functions,
and that's what's
shown over here.
Now let's take a look at
the accepting states for M.
The natural thing to do is look
at the set of pairs of states,
where we have a pair of states--
a pair of accepting states,
one from the first machine
and one from the second machine.
But if you're
thinking with me, you
realize that this is
not the right thing.
What is DFAs?
Did I would call
them DFA somewhere?
Oh, somebody else is probably
doing that in the chat.
The DFA-- careful what
notation you're using.
We haven't introduced DFAs yet.
We'll do that next on Thursday.
But these are DFAs.
These are just finite automata,
Deterministic Finite Automata.
That's why the D.
Anyway, so this is
actually not right,
because if you think
about what this is saying,
it says that both components
have to be accepting.
And you want either
one to be accepting.
So this is not good.
This would be the wrong
way of defining it.
That actually gives the
intersection language.
And really, kind
of along the way,
it's proving closure
under intersection,
which we don't care
about but might
be useful to have in our back
pocket sometime in the future.
In order to get
closure under a union,
we have to write it this
slightly more complicated
looking way, which says the
pair, what you want to have is
either the first state is
an accepting state and then
any state for the
second element,
or any state for
the first element
and an accepting state
for the second element.
That's what it means to have the
union, to be doing the union.
OK?
So let's do-- oh,
here's a quick check-in.
So let's do another poll here.
We thought we were
done with these.
Again-- oh, here we go.
So it was too complicated to
write it out in the polls,
so I actually put it up
on the slide for you.
So all I'm asking is
that if M1 has k1 states
and M2 has k2 states, how
many states does M have?
Is it the sum, the sum of
the squares, or the product?
OK, you have to think
about the states of M, what
do they look like?
And come on, guys.
All right, ending the
poll, sharing results.
Yes, indeed, it is-- most
of you got it correct.
It is C, the product.
Because when you look at the
number of pairs of states
from M1 and M2, you
need all possible pairs.
And so it's the number of
states in M1 times the number
of states in M2.
So make sure you understand
that and think about that
so that you're
following and get this.
All right, so
let's move on here.
So we have another
five minutes or so.
Let's start thinking about
closure under concatenation.
So if we have two
regular languages,
so is the
concatenation language.
We're going to
try to prove that.
We won't finish, but we'll at
least get our creative juices
going about it.
So we're going to do
the same scheme here.
We're going to take two
machines for A1 and A2
and build a machine for the
concatenation language out
of those two.
So here are the two machines
for A1 and A2 written down.
And now here is the
concatenation language.
And I'm going to propose
to you a strategy--
which is not going
to work, but it still
is going to be a good
intuition to have.
So what I'm going to do is
I'm going to make a copy of--
OK, let's understand what
M is supposed to do first.
So M should accept its input.
So think about this.
M is doing the
concatenation language.
So it's given a string.
And it has to answer, is it
in the concatenation language
A1A2 or not?
So it should accept it if
there's some way to divide w
into two pieces where M1 accepts
the first piece and M2 accepts
the second piece.
So here would be the picture.
OK?
And now we have to try to
make a machine which is
going to solve this intuition.
So how would you
do that yourself?
I'm giving you w.
And you can simulate M1 and M2.
So the natural thing
is you're going
to start out by
simulating M1 for a while
and then shift into
simulating M2 for a while,
because that's what's
supposed to be happening
as you're processing the input.
So I'm going to suggest that in
terms of the diagram like this.
So we have here M1
and M2 copied here.
And what I propose doing
is connecting M1 to M2
so that when M1 has
accepted its input,
we're going to jump to
M2, because that's perhaps
the first part of w.
And now we're going to have M2
process the second part of w.
So the way I'm
going to implement
that is by declassifying
the start state of M2,
having transition symbols from
the accepting states of M1
to M2, and then removing these
guys here as accepting states.
And we would have to figure
out what sort of labels
to apply here.
But, actually, this
reasoning doesn't work.
It's tempting, but flawed.
Because-- what goes wrong?
What happens is that--
it might be that when M1 has
accepted an initial part of w
and then it wants M2
to accept the rest,
it might fail because M2
doesn't accept the rest.
And what you might have
been better off doing
is waiting longer
in M1, because there
might have been some
other later place
to split w, which
is still valid.
Splitting w in the
first place where
you have M1 accepting
an initial part
may not be the optimal
place to split w.
You might want to wait
later, and then you'll
have a better chance
of accepting w.
So I'm not sure if
you quite follow that.
But, in fact, it doesn't work.
The question is
where to split w,
and it's challenging,
because how do you
know where to split w?
Because it depends upon what--
it depends on y, and
you haven't seen y yet.
So when you try to think about
it that way, it looks hopeless.
But, in fact, it's still true.
And we'll see how to
do that on Thursday.
So just to recap
what we did today,
we did our
introductory stuff, we
defined finite automata,
regular languages.
We defined the regular
operations and expressions.
We showed that the
regular languages
are closed under union.
We started closure under
intersection, to be continued.